Well,
I grew up,
I was born nearly 60 years ago,
so I was a child of the 60s,
basically,
which sort of a rough blank.
Uh,
I really started growing up,
I think in the 70s.
I went to lab rock kid,
but Dublin,
Ireland in them days,
it was a very dark place as in it was a
very poor almost toward the world.
Uh,
we are going through economically,
the whole world is going through a
recession at the moment while baby,
the 60s,
the 70s and the 80s in Ireland was a
real recession.
It wasn't a pleasant place,
was massive unemployment.
We had huge political problems with the
north.
Uh,
it was dull and gray.
And so I formed a band and tried to
escape it all.
So it's a great country,
a really beautiful,
great country,
but it's had its troubles.
And the last 15 years we had one of the
biggest economic booms,
we,
we became overnight.
We became almost the wealthiest country
in Europe.
And last year the bubble burst.
But I think a few bubbles of Burston a
few countries.
So we're all going through the same
thing.
So,
but let's say Ireland in the 70s and the
80s.
It was tough.
But if you grow up with a tough
background,
like she's strong.
One of the biggest problems I find
with Irish politics and the economic
thing was after,
after the war,
after World War Two,
most of the European countries started
to develop economically and socially.
But whatever way,
the Catholic church,
they took a grip and they almost go over
into the country.
I mean,
we were almost like a dictatorship at
there's good and bad and,
but we experienced an awful lot of bad,
uh,
especially from the institutions that
taught children to Christian brothers
and Cetera.
And all those stories are all coming out
now,
not just in Ireland and in Canada,
all over the world.
So it was pretty intense.
It was that
the Catholic church,
we're almost there.
We're like our Edgar j hoover,
if you know what I mean.
They ruled the roost,
but it had a huge,
profound influence on me in that as you
get older,
you realize that you can't blame
everything,
but there's good and bad and things get
missed directed.
So I would call myself a black Catholic.
You know,
I still have this attraction to it
because all religions I'm not a fan of.
I'm a fan of sort of belief and
spirituality.
So I would be,
I would be into Christ rather than the
Catholics.
I was a very shy child.
Uh,
I didn't like football.
I didn't like the usual stuff that was
shoved,
that sports were always shoved down yet.
And the Gaelic language,
which I've actually disliked as a kid.
But,
um,
as I grow up,
I quite like it.
My real name isn't Gavin.
I was given Gavin Friday by my friends.
I,
I'm Christen phenomena and the V,
which is Gaelic and there's no actual
English translation and I hated it as a
kid.
But as I,
as I grow up,
I said,
I went,
no,
I like it.
My main influences were I loved,
I loved art.
I mean,
it sounds a little pretentious to say I
was into art,
but I like drawing.
I liked music.
Music was my outlet from day one.
You know,
I was giving you an image of,
of Ireland being this dull,
gray,
massive unemployment.
And not much going on.
And the future was the Dole Q,
uh,
or,
for me the window of hope was music and
books.
So I fell in love with sort of t rex and
David Bowie,
very young.
And they sort of said,
hey,
you don't have to live in this
north side of Dublin.
That's all gray and depressed.
You can be a spider and go to Mars.
So,
uh,
music,
I'm books too.
I read avidly as a kid.
So,
and that's the beautiful thing about
books and music and,
and even movies is that you can actually
escape.
You can,
you can go into other worlds.
It's village was an imaginary place
really.
It was the group of young guys that grew
up around the same area.
I grew up on a street called Cedar Wood
Road.
Um,
and by coincidence,
my best friends that around the age of
10 became at a guide called Bano.
And another guy called Googie.
Uh,
and we just,
it was music again,
if I thought that that pulled us
together.
I lived in at the bottom end of the
street and they lived at the top end and
I was quite shy as a little kid.
Uh,
but they find me quite interesting cause
I had the right albums underneath my
arm.
You know,
those days where you carry the latest
bowie album or roxy music album as you
go to school.
I mean,
you can't play an album at school,
but you were being cool just showing,
look what I got and I'm not into
meatloaf.
I'm into Bowie.
Yeah.
And so I attracted their attention and I
had long hair and earrings when it was
quite a risky thing to do in Dublin.
I mean we didn't have the liberation
that America and Britain had in,
in,
in the 60s,
but I did always look to England and
America mainly because of the music that
came from that.
But we became friends,
true music.
And we had real names,
as I said,
phenomenon via Derek Roan on a dreadful
nine.
And Paul Hewson.
Uh,
we gave each other nicknames just the
way most kids do,
you know,
but the nicknames,
I had more to do with
how we physically looked or our essence.
And I had quite square features as a,
as a young kid,
uh,
almost like this,
there was the surge was add on,
on the TV is search pipe called
[inaudible].
And that used to just come wyvern piping
and this big square pipe would come.
Um,
I can be full on at moments.
So I was called [inaudible] for a while,
but I'm a bit sauce softer and a little
softer than a [inaudible] search pipes.
So they changed that to Gavin?
No,
I didn't choose it as bundling.
Gogi you gave it to me and then Friday
was added because
I have a talent of
getting home at most people.
Um,
so it's a bit of a man Friday thing and
we gave each of these nicknames and,
and then we,
we didn't,
we had similar interests.
We were into sounds really pretentious.
The 12,
13 year old kids were like into art and
poetry,
but we were,
we weren't into football,
we weren't into making music or being
into music and painting and stuff like
that.
And we call this sort of little gang,
Lipton village and we made up imaginary
games and it's just one day we form
bands and when they would make movies
and when they will do this and one day
we'll do that.
But I think a lot of kids do this in
their own way except 25,
30 years later,
legends happens because some of us have
become quite well known.
So the myth becomes magical.
So that I tend to sort of see it very
practical for me when I go out for a
drink bottle combined the pints cause he
has more money than me.
We're the same guys.
That's a tough one.
Uh,
I've always,
I've always done,
I mean,
yeah,
as a performer on stage,
I tend to sort of troll myself into the
character,
whatever I've written about.
So it depends on how I'm writing or when
I'm writing about
Eh,
a lot.
A lot of singers don't really know who
they are.
They sort of,
uh,
they have this massive insecurity and
there's massive
ego
and then sort of pulled the between
both.
I mean,
why do you want a lot of the people to
look at you all the time and listen to
you something going on there.
There's this sort of need to express and
attention.
It's not just ego,
it's,
it's some sort of complex thing.
And sometimes you know,
you,
you create characters to say something
you want to say and a,
and then you just throw yourself into
that.
In the last couple of years I've been
acting a lot more of the one or two
movies.
I've done a lot of work with the Royal
Shakespeare Company.
Well that's been an intense baby.
I can tell you that.
I love,
I love the way an Irish man that can
hardly speak proper English is doing
shakespeare.
So I find that extraordinary as I got
older.
But
I always see music,
live shows,
performances as moments.
And to really get there,
you just got to actually get into the
essence,
flushing the blood.
Maurice Caesar.
Um,
I worked with for a round from around
the 87 till around 2004.
How long is that?
It's a long time.
And
I started working in a club called the
Blue Jays as I started this club called
the Blue Jays in,
in,
uh,
post and prunes and I painted for a
couple of years and then I needed that
light I was telling you about.
I needed that attention or I needed
to open up and show people what's inside
me.
I don't know.
Uh,
so I wanted to perform again,
but in a low key way.
So I did this speakeasy sort of
Vaudeville club called the Blue Jesus,
where I met up with Maurice.
I,
I'd come from a sort of a punk rock
avant garde background.
But as I,
as I sort of ended the band,
I started like getting into more two
more sort of structured music and even
classical and jazz.
Uh,
I started realizing,
hey,
before 1960 the was good music,
you know,
so,
uh,
I decided I wanted to work with somebody
that was trained and Morris was
classically trained.
So that journey we made three albums and
numerous,
numerous sidetrack and score and played
about 10 years of shows.
But it just sort of,
it w w you know,
Mara says playing with me this weekend,
uh,
we're still friends,
but I just think the relationship came
to an end spontaneously.
He wanted to move to West Cork and plant
trees with his wife.
I didn't
certain things kick in when you hit your
late forties and shit,
you know,
nothing really to do with me.
I was,
I think it's going back years.
I think it was on some TV situation and
Archie and
a lot of people think a file.
What's he out now?
He's doing this,
he's doing,
so what are you going to do next?
And I saw,
I don't know,
what do you want to do?
And honestly,
I don't know.
I just want to get better.
Um,
who do you want to work?
I don't know what I mean.
He says,
well,
where would you play?
I said,
look,
I'd love to play somewhere classics
somewhere.
Legendary,
a place where music was when music was a
Carnegie Hall.
I just set it like that.
So became this sort of between my
friends and different people.
Oh God was going to play Carnegie Hall,
a Guy Who's going to play Carnegie,
oh blah,
blah blah.
Oh,
maybe you'll do shakespeare in Carnegie
Hall.
And just became this thing over the
years.
Like I could joke almost,
eh.
And then,
you know,
my friends as I was talking about were
all turning 50 slowly or quickly.
Uh,
and Gogi turned 50 in May.
I went,
a gang of us,
went to a really nice hotel,
had a beautiful weekend,
and we had a few drinks and my good
friend bonuses,
uh,
Hey,
you know what you're doing for your
50th.
And I said,
you know what?
I don't really care.
Whatever.
Once I'm with my friends and loved ones
and whatever.
And he says,
I know what you're doing for your 50th.
I says,
really?
He says,
yeah,
you're going to be working and you've
gotta be making a show,
you're going to be working for red.
Um,
when I have a few drinks on me,
I can talk,
but I shut up for the night.
So I was a little taken aback and it was
sort of out of my control.
I went,
what's this about?
But the guy who's putting the show
together,
how wilner I've worked with since 1988
and he's a little bit of a genius.
Well,
that's an understatement.
He is a genius in my mind.
And I've done many of us collaborations
and shows and he gets it.
Let's just see who wants to play with
you.
And that's true.
The dice up in the air and see what
comes down.
And I mean,
you've seen the cost.
It's pretty extraordinary
from Joe Grades,
Rufus Wainwright's,
Martha Wainwright,
the Courtney love to Marine Mckee,
Eric Mingus,
Lydia lunch.
She,
you too,
as you've never seen you two as in it's
Bono,
it's out of,
it's Larry.
It's edge to some extra virgin prunes,
Gogi and Dick,
two actresses,
the incredible Elizabeth Ashley,
chloe.
Well
and more and surprise guests,
Laurie Anderson and I,
after I leave this interview,
I'll go to rehearse with Anthony
Haggerty,
uh,
for a few songs.
Um,
so what I'm most excited about is a lot
of music today is so over rehearsed,
so worked out.
So unspontaneous these events,
we've got three days of rehearsal and
just putting in a lot of people
abduction and thoughts and emails and
letters and conversations.
But you're getting a group of musicians
almost like a workshop that loved music
that are like pushing it out there and
spontaneously doing something.
And that's a rare thing these days.
And this,
I don't know what's going to happen and
I love that because in these days and
age,
everything is so ordered an anal and
music is about spirits and spontaneity.
And that's what we're going to do on
Sunday night.
Do you think are going to live to a
hundred?
I'll have to,
maybe bono can arrange that.
That would be interesting.
Hey,
bondo.
Thank you for my 50th.
Can you make me live another 50 years?
Uh,
you know,
it's just such a pleasure to be on an
honor that,
and you know what's so great is that
we're making money for AIDS and Africa
is,
it was a lot of love and spontaneity.
We're doing something creative.
That's what I love about Rad.
It's,
it's not just a charity.
Give us money,
give us money.
It's being innovative.
Like,
here's a show,
but you won't see anywhere else.
And you can come and whatever you pay
for your ticket,
it's going somewhere.
You can go and buy a pair of our manny
shades like Bono,
but the money goes to Africa.
That's,
it's quite cool.
But I,
I,
I'm actually quite modest.
All of us as a nice,
all one is,
is,
is a drink at midnight on Sunday night.
And I'll be a very happy man.